In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion, for June 4th, on which we commemorate, saints Martha
and Mary, sisters of St. Lazarus, the friend of Christ.
These two holy women, sisters of Lazarus, the friend of Christ, lived in Bethany, a village
situated not far from Jerusalem.
One day, Jesus was received in their house.
Martha, the older of the two, busied herself in preparing to serve the master, and, seeing
that her sister Mary remained sitting silently at Jesus' feet, listening to his divine
words, said in irritation.
Lord, does thou not care that my sister have left me to serve alone?
Bid her therefore that she helped me.
The Lord replied, Martha, thou art careful and troubled about many things, but one thing
is needful.
Sometime later, shortly before the Lord's passion, Lazarus became ill and died.
The two sisters sent to inform Jesus, but he arrived at the house only on the fourth day
after Lazarus' death.
Martha immediately ran to meet him while Mary stayed in the house, where a great number
of friends and family had come to console the sisters.
The Lord assured Martha that her brother would rise again, and Martha showed her faith in
him as Son of God.
Calling her sister, they went together to the tomb.
The command of Jesus, the dead man, came out of the tomb.
His hands and feet still bound with cloth, and his face still covered with the shroud.
Six days before the Passover, a banquet was organized in Jesus' honor at Bethany, and Lazarus
was there.
Martha busied herself as usual with the serving, while Mary taking a pound of very costly
ointment, anointed the Lord's feet with it, and wiped his feet with her hair.
When Judas, the miser, protested against such a waste, saying that the ointment could have
been sold, the Lord declared that it was for his burial that Mary had kept the perfumed
ointment.
After the ascension, Martha and Mary accompanied Lazarus in the preaching of the good news
of the resurrection through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our
God, have mercy on us and save us.